JOHN VEIZADES: So my
name is John Veizades.
I'm a product manager
at Google, and I
work a lot on how enterprise
customers connect to our cloud
infrastructure.
And today's talk is going
to be exactly about that.
What we're going to be covering
is a little bit about--
and you're going to hear this
throughout the whole week--
I'm going to talk a little
bit about the Google
infrastructure, what we--
how you connect to us today
and then talk a little
bit about how you
connect to us tomorrow or soon.
Talk a little bit about
architectures, deployment
architectures and how you
can use our cloud networking
to build enterprise networks
that extend out to the cloud.
Something about how we
monitor these systems, what
we do around monitoring.
Some discussion about how you
can get better application
performance when you
come to the cloud.
And finally, a little bit about
the pricing of all this stuff.
So infrastructure, and
if you go to about half
of the sessions in
this conference,
you're going to see a
picture something like this.
And what this is
trying to point out
is where are all the
Cloud data centers?
When you build an
enterprise network,
you have Cloud data
centers as well.
Or I should say you
have data centers.
This is saying where
Google's data centers are.
And the ones in
green are showing
the ones that are available
today and all the ones in blue
are data centers that are in
the process of being built out.
The numbers tell
you how many zones
each one of those
data centers has.
And as you can see,
what we're trying to do
is cover the globe
with data centers
that are close to customers.
Because millisecond closeness
means application performance.
So it's really important to
get that level of connectivity.
The other thing that we
have, and if I take away
all the Cloud data
centers, what pops out
is all these little lines,
this is Google's backbone.
This is what we have been
spending years and years
on building.
Predominantly it was to
service the applications
that Google is known
for-- search and YouTube
and Gmail and all those.
What we're doing with our
Cloud networking infrastructure
is giving you access
to all of this.
Now you don't see it because
it's hidden under the covers,
but your application data
runs over this infrastructure.
And it's an infrastructure that
Google continues to build on.
So, this is what it
looks like today.
If you see this little--
there's this thing
that says 2018, that's
a fiber cable that
we're dropping
from somewhere in Portland,
Oregon area to somewhere
in Japan.
And we're going to drop in
a little over 100 terabytes
of infrastructure there to
give you more capacity to--
originally it was to
give Google more capacity
but in short, it's also to give
our customers more capacity
as you grow.
So, we're expanding--
in summary,
Google Cloud is an
expanding platform.
It's expanding to cover--
give you a global footprint,
a footprint that's
close to your customers, that
gives you high availability,
local availability,
the ability to take VMs
and get them closer
to your customers
and continue to drive the
scale that you guys are
driving us to build.
So today, there are a
number of ways to connect
to this infrastructure.
The first one is something
what we call direct peering.
This is where you
have a private ASN--
sorry, a public ASN
and you're connecting
to our infrastructure at one
of our points of presence.
I'll go into it where
are points of presence
are in just a second.
This is public peering.
So when you do that, you get
all of Google's routing table
and you expose your
routing table to us.
Another way to do that is
through a carrier interconnect.
And that's where you go through
carriers that you know and love
and connect to us through
their infrastructure to us.
And finally, if you can't
do either one of these two
or you have a place where you
don't have a lot of capacity,
you don't need a
lot of capacity,
you can connect to us
using a VPN tunnel.
So I'll go into some
detail about that as well.
So our Cloud interconnects.
First of all, when you go
through those direct peering
links, you do get
a dedicated link.
That means you have--
how do you say it--
I wouldn't say enhanced
security but you're just
going over a cross-connect
in a colocation facility.
So it's in a protected--
physically protected
environment.
And from a performance
standpoint,
you're getting
carrier level SLAs,
you're getting locations in
70 locations and 33 countries,
so it's a place where
you can get closer to us
and get better
performance out of it.
And finally, a lot of
customers use these methods
for the last reason which is
there's lower egress costs when
you come and meet us
versus when we have
to carry your traffic to you.
And finally with
those systems, you
get access to the whole
set of Google properties.
So if you're an enterprise
customer who's rolling out
G Suite and you want to
have a close connection that
doesn't go over
the internet, these
are great solutions for you.
Unfortunately, a lot of the
customers, what you really need
is a pri-- extend your
private network into Cloud.
And today the way you do that--
sorry-- is with our
IPsec VPN solution.
So our IPsec VPN solution
is a virtualised solution
that runs in the Cloud.
It's a scale out VPN
so each tunnel starts
at about three
gigabits per second
but you can scale that out
based on deploying more
infrastructure on top of that.
And what it does
is it lets you take
your RFC1918 space, your
private address space
and extend it to Cloud.
And we do that with a
couple entities here.
There's a cloud router
and a VPN gateway.
VPN gateway [INAUDIBLE]
terminates your IPsec sessions
and the Cloud router gives
you the BGP reachability
of everything in your Cloud.
I'm going to make one
comment on Cloud Router
because I'm going to use
this throughout the rest
of the presentation.
I want you guys to understand
what does the Cloud Router do?
Yes, it is a BGP endpoint
but that's all it is.
It is the control plane of
our routing infrastructure.
So when you terminate
a BGP session
on the Cloud Router, what
it does is it programs
the routes into our
SDN infrastructure.
If you-- I don't know if you've
ever read about something
called Andromeda.
Andromeda is Google's
SDN network architecture.
There are some great
presentations on it.
I'm not going to
cover that here.
There is actually some
presentations online that
go into a lot of detail there.
But Cloud Router is not the
typical Juniper or Cisco router
that all the packets
go through it.
It just programs the--
it's the control plane that
programs the data plane.
So packets don't go through
that so it doesn't--
we don't need a
scale out router.
It's a scale out network.
So I just wanted to cover
that before I use it
in other contexts and
you guys understand
what does the Cloud Router do.
When you scale out
VPN too, if you
need more than three
gigabits per second,
you can use multiple tunnels and
use ECMP across those tunnels
to get greater capacity.
And we have customers
doing that today
to drive tens of gigs of
traffic into their Cloud
infrastructure.
But that seems a
little bit yesterday.
So what we're doing
today is announcing the--
same products that are coming
out later on this year,
actually later on
this quarter, that
will allow you to
extend that using
more traditional networking
architectures other than VPN.
So specifically, we're
announcing two products.
One is called
Private Interconnect.
Another is called
Partner Interconnect.
Both of these
techniques allow you
to extend your RFC1918 address
space from your premise
to the Cloud.
With the Private
Interconnect, this
is where you meet us in one
of our colocation facilities
and you extend a cross-connect
from your routed infrastructure
to our edge.
And with Partner Interconnect
is where you go using a carrier.
And they can offer you a sub
rate interface or actually
a full 10 gig interface to
our Cloud infrastructure.
So, Private Interconnect, this
is where an enterprise customer
comes to Google.
And Partner Interconnect is
where an enterprise customer
goes to a carrier and
then comes to Google.
Again, the goal here is
to extend your network
to our network using your
private address space
into Google's-- in your private
address space in the Google
Cloud.
And it doesn't require
the use of any VPN devices
and uses standard routing, as
I'll go into it just a second.
So, in a more pictorial view,
with Private Interconnect,
there's the Google
peering edge and there's
your peering router.
And you're connecting to us
in a colocation facility.
That means your
network is connecting
to your compute
instances in the Cloud.
And with Partner
Interconnect, you're
coming through a
service provider
from your router to
their infrastructure
into the Google Cloud.
This, as in the
previous diagram,
these are all layer
two connections.
And I'll talk about how
you do the layer three
extensions in just a second.
There are carriers that offer
you a service like a Metro E
kind of a service
where they offer you
an ethernet connection
and you don't
have to worry about the
routing infrastructure.
So there are two methods
that carriers offer,
one where you have
to deal with BGP
and another one where you
don't have to deal with BGP.
So where do you connect to us?
Shortly, when we come
out with the product,
you'll be able to
connect to us where
all these green areas are.
And over the course
of 2017, we'll
be lighting up a lot
of these areas in blue.
These are points of
presence that Google
has across the globe.
So what is a point of presence?
For instance in
Chicago, we're actually
in two locations in Chicago.
We're in CoreSite
and in Equinix.
In Frankfurt, we're in four
locations in Frankfurt.
So when we say that you're--
we have a metro availability,
what we're doing is actually
offering you in a number
of connections in that metro.
And in each one of
those connections,
we offer multiple no shared fate
paths to Google infrastructure.
So if for instance, if you
come into CoreSite in Chicago,
what you'll see is there are two
locations that you can connect
to us in Chicago
in CoreSite, what
we call a zone 1 and a zone 2.
And there is no shared fate
between the two of them.
So if you're building a
highly reliable network,
you probably want to connect
in zone 1 and zone 2.
I'll go to high availability
and architectures
for high availability later
on in this slide deck.
So in general, it
doesn't matter where
you connect to us in
that metro, you're
connecting into the
Google infrastructure
but in multiple sites
in any one metro.
So a little-- some comments,
this is all well and good,
but what do I have to do?
Couple of things, this
is all single mode fiber.
We support LACP
for link bonding.
So we offer 10 gig interfaces.
You can link bond across
multiple 10 gig interfaces
to go up from 10 gig
up to 80 and even more.
If you go for more, please come
and talk to us because there's
better ways of doing that.
You have to support
a link local address.
So if you're doing
the private solution,
you have to have a link
local address on your router.
You have to have a private
ASN that you exchange with us.
802.1q VLAN tagging, and
that's how we'll do traffic
separation.
I'll go into the details
about traffic separation
in just a bit.
And this is all using
iPv4 link local access.
So, a little bit more detail.
So link local address
between your router.
And the router you connect to
is actually the Cloud Router
that we talked about earlier.
This is where your
virtual connection ends up
being is on your Cloud
router in your project.
So in that project, you can
then connect to VM instances
and you're taking your
private address space,
you're going over a
layer 2 connection
to the Google Cloud
infrastructure
and to your project instances
running in the Google Cloud.
So, if you're in
multiple regions,
you'd have a Cloud Router
in one region, a Cloud
Router in another
region, and then you'd
have VLAN tags going
between both of them.
So this shows one VLAN
tag going to one region
and another VLAN tag would
go to another region.
All those instances can talk
to each other over the Google
Cloud backbone.
That's all well and good,
but let's get better.
So we're announcing a
feature to Cloud Router
called global routing.
What global routing does is
why should I-- if I use BGP,
I should be able to advertise
region 2 out of region 1
so now I only have to
deploy one Cloud Router.
That means I only have to peer
with Google in one location
and now you have access to
our whole infrastructure.
Remember-- and this is something
that maybe we don't drill
into you guys enough--
is that the network that
you have in a Cloud project
is a network that
spans the globe.
And this is what
I'm showing here, is
that even though you're
connecting in one region,
you have connectivity
to all the regions
that you have projects--
your project has VMs in.
So that means you get access
to that infrastructure
as showed in earlier slides.
And if you're a multinational
company that wants to,
for instance, do web serving out
to people all over the globe,
you only really need
one connection to us
and that gives you
access to infrastructure
across the globe.
Now there are customers that
have-- actually most customers
have multiple projects.
So you might have a dev project
and you might have your release
project.
You don't want the
two networks to meet.
That would be a very bad thing.
It gives you the chance
of cross-pollination
of information and hackers
can get through one network
into the other.
And most customers want to
keep their production network
separate from your
development network.
So what you do is you can
have a project with a Cloud
Router here and another project
with a Cloud Router here.
There's VLAN tagging that
separates the traffic
between those two projects.
And on your side, you would do
VRFs to separate the traffic
on your enterprise network.
So this gives you one link into
Google but multiple projects
using that link and
having traffic separation
across those multiple projects.
The other thing--
actually, there's
a talk this afternoon
at 4:00 that's
going to go into a
lot of detail on XPN,
which is our cross project
networking solution,
also known as a shared VPC.
So, what is a shared
VPC in Google's world?
What happens is that
you have a host project
and you have service projects.
Your networking for
those service projects
ends up in the host project.
So this is where you virtually
connect to the Google
Cloud in that project.
This is where all your
network resources are,
these are where your
firewall policies can live.
And what that lets you
do is have a separation
of concerns between the folks
that are worried about security
and networking and those that
are worried about development.
So this lets you share a
resource like a network
connection to multiple projects
without those projects really
needing to know about the
physical infrastructure
of building a network.
So you can monitor--
you can have one set of
people monitoring your network
infrastructure and
another set of people
doing all the production
deployments of your VMs
and all of that.
So you have that
separation of concerns,
you have that separation of
management responsibilities,
and that extends to
the IM roles that
are associated with these
host and service projects.
Again, this afternoon,
there's going
to be a presentation
that goes into a lot more
technical detail
about a shared VPC
and how you can use
it in your projects.
So as I said, we were
going to talk a little bit
about high availability.
When you deploy network
infrastructure anywhere,
you're going to want
to do multiple links
into our infrastructure.
One of the reasons is that we
can't support an SLA for one
single connection.
We do maintenance on
all this infrastructure
and when we do maintenance, we
would take your network out,
which is not a nice thing.
So, what we suggest doing is
in one colocation facility,
have multiple links.
That gives you the
ability to have redundancy
and we give you the
benefit of having no shared
fate between those two links.
But in addition
to that, and a lot
of customers want
to go this route,
is that you want to
do more than that.
You want to have
multiple connections
in multiple regions.
And the reason you
want to do that
is because you want to deal with
failover, metro level failover.
If your infrastructure
in a metro fails,
you can failover to
another metro area.
So, now you have two routers.
What we've also done
in these two routers
is we've built the
ability to use BGP the way
it's meant to be used.
So you can have different
route preferences
in each one of those routers.
So, let's say this
facility is in London
and this facility is in the
Bay Area, in San Francisco.
If you get a cable
cut here in London,
your traffic off your network
would end up in San Francisco
because the BGP route
preferences would tell you
that's what you want to do.
You'd see that there was
a disconnect connectivity
to your London facility and
you'd route your traffic
to another facility.
So this gives you--
what we're doing is starting
to extend the Cloud Router,
the network infrastructure
to look more
like a traditional
enterprise network.
With the same level
of redundancy,
the same level of
failover, the same way
of doing all of
these things that you
do in a large
multi-region, multi-country
enterprise network.
Oh one other-- one
last thing on this.
Also when you think about--
I used to do a lot
of work with telcos.
And telcos are all about,
it has to be five nines
and they're starting to
think about six nines.
So with this kind of
an infrastructure,
you start building that level
of failover, that level of SLA
by multiplying the number
of connections you have.
So with a description,
if you were
to build a network that
looks something like this,
you'd be able to
build a network that
had a five nines reliability.
A number of customers
have come to us
and said, yeah that private
address space is really good.
But what I really want to do
is I have some public address
space and I would like to
back up that public address
space with infrastructure
in the Cloud.
And there's a way
to do that in GCP.
The first thing you would
do is at the VM level,
you'd attach an IP address
to each one of those VMs.
So you're taking that
public IP address
and attaching it at
the operating system
level of the VM.
The second thing
you'd do is you'd--
with another feature
that's coming out shortly--
is you'd be able to change the
route that is being advertised.
Today, the Cloud Router
advertises in a very static way
what routes are available.
We're adding a feature
called flexible routing that
will allow you to specify which
routes you would advertise.
A reason you'd want to
do this is for instance,
you may have a
production network
that you're not ready to go
and expose to the whole world,
that you want to
have it all ready.
So you want the routing
infrastructure ready.
You'll be able to flip
a bit on that network
and then it'll start to be
advertised off the Cloud
Router.
It's a way too predictably
release routes out to your
on premise infrastructure.
So that's a feature
that's coming out.
So, in Cloud Router,
you'd add the prefixes
for those public IPs that you
want to advertise over BGP.
Then you'd add a static
route from the private IP.
Because these VM instances
will have a Google private IP
and you need to know how to
get the reverse traffic back.
So you'd put a static route,
taking that private IP
to the public IP of the VM.
Sorry, from the public IP
to the private IP of the VM.
And finally, you'd
set up your router
so that advertises as those
to the rest of the world.
And that is a method
for getting public IPs
into the Google infrastructure
that are your own public IPs.
Because today, the only
way you can use a public IP
is if you take something
out of our range.
So, for monitoring,
so now we've given you
a link to our
infrastructure and you've
decided to provision
10 gig and you
have no idea how much of
that link you're using.
So there'll be-- this
is a mock up of the user
interface that you'd see
in the Cloud Console.
And we'll do things
like link utilization,
drops, items like that.
We'll also give you--
suggest that you
get a ping endpoint
so you can measure round trip
times and monitor that as well.
And all of these statistics
will be available in Stackdriver
so you can actually
extract them and put them
into your own console.
So you don't have to go
to the Google Console
to get all this data.
You can actually get it
out and use it on your own.
Another thing we're changing--
we've done some fundamental
changes in how you interconnect
to the Google infrastructure.
And doing fundamental
changes means you probably
fundamentally want to
change the way we describe
that in the Cloud Console.
So today, we're
interconnected, as you see,
there's something called VPN.
That's going to change so
it would be interconnect.
And that will subsume VPN
and private and partner
interconnect.
So you'd have one place to
go in our user interface
to control those interconnect
methods into the Cloud.
So, now you've moved your
applications to the Cloud.
You've connected to us
in a variety of areas.
It's still different.
It's not your data
center, right?
It's not the rack of machines
that's down the hall.
And what we found is that
customers have a problem,
their applications have
problems with this.
Because we've changed--
fundamentally,
we've changed some
of the network, some
of the basic
networking parameters
that applications are used to.
And what that big change
we've done is we've
changed the latency between
your front end, the application,
and the back end.
Whether it be a database
server or whether it
be some other REST API that
that application is using.
And those changes
mean that you may
want to think about changing
the way the application behaves.
So I'm going to go into
some details about how
you can change the
application to make sure
that you're getting the
most of our network.
And it really has to do about
something called the bandwidth
delay product.
And let me go into a little
bit about why-- what this is.
So if you look at typical Cloud
latencies, and I'm throwing--
showing you three Google
regions that we have--
and the average latency to
each one of those regions
from our pop locations.
So if you have an instance
running in our US Central
region and you connect
to us at the closest
place you can connect to
that US Central region,
you're still about
10 milliseconds away
from those VMs.
In US East, it's about
10 to 25 milliseconds.
And finally in Europe,
because it's a smaller place,
it's about five to
seven milliseconds.
That's different.
And the difference is.
Profound because
what you'll see,
and now I'm going to go into a
little bit of details about how
TCP works, if you think
about it, what TCP does
is it sends a bunch
of data down the pipe.
And it sends a Windows
worth of data down the pipe.
When you're in the
same data center,
your application
and the back end
are running in the
same data center.
The time it takes to send
that is fairly quick.
Well, it's the time
to take-- regardless
of where you're at, the
time it takes to send
it is still about the same.
What's very different
is how long it
takes to acknowledge that data.
Because your data
goes down the pipe,
has to get to its destination
before an acknowledgement can
come back.
And on a network
that is less than a
millisecond in delay,
this time it's very short.
But as you get to even short
delays like seven milliseconds,
if you use the default
settings in a TCP kernel,
you're going to get
really bad performance.
And I get a lot of calls
from customers saying,
I connected to you.
I have these big pipes
to you and I still
get really lousy performance.
Why?
And they're
forgetting one thing,
is I need to change the TCP
behavior to take advantage
of the--
well not take advantage,
to remediate the issues
you have with this
milliseconds of latency
that you've added
to your application.
And the way you do
that is by increasing
the advertised window
in your TCP session.
So rather than advertising
in the default window,
you want to extend that
window so that you can send
more data to the remote site.
Now this doesn't help
applications that--
especially HTTP
applications that
are doing small
transactions all the time,
but it really
affects applications
that are trying to
move lots of data.
And that's where
more often than not,
you complain about slowness.
You're doing an upload
into a GCS Cloud Bucket.
You're taking the
movie you just finished
rendering and downloading it.
Doing those kinds of
things can take a long time
if you don't take into account
the delay bandwidth product.
And the way to do that is by
increasing the window size.
And when you increase the
window size, what happens
is that you send more data
and you acknowledge more data
at the same time, meaning
you can keep the pipe full.
So if you're getting
10 gigabit pipes to us,
you really want to keep
the 10 gigabits full,
especially if you're doing
these large data transfers.
So, just some notes on--
one last note on this subject
is that many of the TCP kernels
are already set up this way.
And the reason I bring this up
is because if you do see that,
it's a good way
to go check this.
And if you do a Wikipedia search
on delay bandwidth product,
there's tons of articles that
go into how you'd go and look
at these features and how you
calculate all these things.
So let's talk briefly about
pricing of the solution.
Because everyone
wants to know how much
they're going to spend.
So, with our public
item, right now it's--
when you're doing
direct peering with us,
we don't charge you
to direct peer with us
and we give you some benefits
on the cost of egress.
So you get a benefit in
price on the cost of egress.
With VPN, you're paying
for the VPN gateway,
and that's roughly about $5
a month for every three--
roughly three gigabits
of large packet data.
With the new solution
that we're coming up with,
Private Interconnect, it's
a $2,500 charge for the port
that we give you, and there's
egress costs on top of that.
With a Partner Connection,
there's a lot of charges,
depending on how you
connect with a partner.
We start at the
partner access pricing,
so whatever they charge
you to connect to us.
And then there's a sliding
scale depending on how much data
you're pumping into
Google on our end as well.
So this gives you a sense
of what the pricing is
of those solutions.
So, I'm almost finished.
So how do you learn more?
If you're really
interested in this,
please talk to your sales
folks, whoever your sales
contact is at Google.
So that they can help
you get into our team,
possibly become
part of the alpha,
and be aware of when the beta
of this solution comes out.
The other area where
you can help a lot
is somewhere in this--
oh, there she is.
There's one of my colleagues in
an orange t-shirt back there.
And they're running a UX
lab down on the first floor.
So if you're interested
in helping us help you
with a great user
interface, they
are more than
happy and more than
willing to listen to you guys
and get you involved in studies
about how we do UX development
at Google so that we
can give you great
user interfaces
and get great solutions back.
And finally, there are
a number of sessions
that cover a number of
aspects of networking.
Unfortunately, one
of them is actually
happening right now
that's two doors down.
But I want to bring this up,
all these sessions are recorded.
So if you miss a
session here, you'll
be able to see at a later time.
So I want to highlight
some of these sessions that
are happening throughout the
course of the next three days.
And I find, I end up
with one on Friday
where we'll be talking
about third party solutions
to networking.
Today Checkpoint, for instance,
announced their VSEC firewall,
so next generation
of firewalls for GCP.
We'll be talking
about that and we'll
be talking about other SSL
VPN, about load balancers,
and other solutions
for enterprise
networking in the Cloud.